I'm not going to be specific because you
don't know it that's why all right done
one well here's another guy that the
machine has tried to destroy repeatedly
uh Tucker Carlson uh this is him calling
out Schiff six years ago 2017. watch
this this is fun
you're you're you're on the Intel
committee let me just ask you one final
question can you look right into the
camera and say I know for a fact the
government of Vladimir Putin was behind
the hacks of John podesta's absolutely
the government of Vladimir Putin was
behind the hacks of our institution and
the dump of John podesta's not only in
the Johnson's email but also in Europe
okay
and Tucker I know they did jumping I
think that Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan you're carrying water for
the Kremlin you're not carrying water
for them you're sitting number of
Congress on the inside Duty and you
can't say You're Gonna you're gonna have
to move your shoulder to RT Russian
television because you know what this is
perfect this is beneath your office
because it's so dumb and you're being
duplicitous I'm asking you did they hack
Vanessa's emails
like that Tucker
oh you set up getting water for Putin
that's pretty hilarious you know when
you when you especially are an apologist
for the criminal that's what you're
doing I'm gonna pop one last time
Congressman look in the camera and say
they hacked John pedestal's emails we
know for a fact that Putin's government
did that you can't and you know you
can't and you're hiding behind uh weasel
words I I just said that
Russians I'm not going to be specific as
well because you don't know it that's
why all right done one you don't know it
and you're alleging it without any
evidence you're ignoring the evidence
because you don't care the fact that it
that it helped uh the Republican
candidate is all you need to know that's
totally false false I just think if
you're going to make a serious
allegation about an actual country with
an actual government you already know
they're not talking about and you don't
isn't that interesting how the story
changes but the tactics remain the same
that's Schiff back in 2017 saying that
Tucker was carrying water for the
Russians now Flash Forward to 2023 when
Tucker is basically the loudest anti-war
person that we have now you may disagree
with that right you may think that we
should allow Ukraine to join NATO and
you may think that we should have this
giant Alliance and we have to turn back
Putin and we should risk World War III I
suppose people can make arguments about
all of those things
but what do they say about the guy
Tucker now it's the same exact thing
you're a Putin apologist you're carrying
water for the Russians when he's
basically saying how about we just don't
March towards world war three uh so it's
not just about mainstream bias towards
certain people it's about the machine
and how it wants to constantly control
the narrative so you are completely
confused about everything all the time
and then you stop trusting the people
who are approximately trying to tell you
something true and then Phil they put up
a guy like shiff and somebody watches it
and go my God that ship's making sense
oh